how does someone know which story they
should write she write the one you're
afraid to tell sure if it scares you
then you you know you need to do it I
have a couple like that right now that
I'm working on I have a play that is
going to be going up off-broadway next
year it was it was actually one of the
very first pieces of writing I had ever
done I was in a group called the Los
Angeles writers centre for years when I
was kind of dipping my toe into writing
and decided I wasn't very good at it but
I had written to play
it's a two-act play and I wrote it in
2007 and it's actually scary how how
applicable it is to today's current
climate it's about a Mexican American
soldier who's injured in Iraq and his
illegal brother has killed what they're
serving over there so this was right
after 9/11 and he comes back to Los
Angeles and he discovers that his two
younger siblings have been put into
foster care and his parents have deport
been deported and I wrote this in 2007
oh yeah and it was it was it's called
borderline and it was actually a
semifinalist at AFF last year again as
soon as as soon as I started to build up
my own confidence in my writing I took
up some stuff and I dusted them off and
I started to submit them out and I'm a
friend of mine who I went to USC with
who runs a theater up in Manhattan and
this is a issue that is that she's very
passionate about and I've never
connected the dots before but I sent it
to her and she said do you want to I
said do you want to read this and she
said yeah absolutely so she read it she
goes why don't we do a reading so we did
a reading in April this year in New York
and we have decided to workshop it and
with the intent of putting it up in the
fall of 2020 now I have not done any of
the rewrites yet because I am silently
criticizing myself because how do I take
the enormity of everything that's going
on right now and put it into a two-act
play and again you know why am I the
person to tell this story and this is
something that I wrestled with and I I
hope it comes out well I hope I tell an
authentic story
and I hope I create something that
really resonates and move people but my
job as a writer is to really take myself
in this particular instance is to take
myself out of it and to put my fear
society you know behind me so I can so I
can draft the piece we need writers
right now more than ever because a lot
of people's voices are being quieted and
this is not the time does it scare you
yeah absolutely
why does it scare you tell that's um you
know I certainly don't want anything to
ring inauthentic or Hollow and of course
you know if I'm if I'm telling a story
that doesn't necessarily relate to you
know my own upbringing you know my
family he's not immigrants I mean
they're they're from Italy but that was
two generations ago so I wasn't directly
impacted by that going up but there are
a lot of people that are hurting right
now there are a lot of people that are
struggling so for me to have to you know
that's a lot of weight to carry on my
shoulders but I put that weight upon
myself because I feel like this is a
very important story to tell and it's
one that I want to tell so I'm doing a
lot of research right now I'm speaking
with immigration attorneys I am reading
you know news articles I'm doing a ton
of research it's it's my job to tell the
story the best that I can I mean I'm
crafting the story as well but I find
you know this is this other piece that I
worked on Daruma this this particular
story it it starts to disabled leads but
the movie is not about their disability
and I I wrote this as a way to deal with
my own grief after a member of my family
became paralyzed in an accident now the
story is not about them it's it's not
about the melody but it's inspired by
them and I went through dozens of drafts
of that script because I wanted to tell
an authentic story now I'm not a
disabled person I the last thing I
wanted to do was to put anything on the
page that was you know inauthentic
offensive
I put that script through so many
sensitivity reads which is a which is an
important thing to do as a writer and
that's not to say I away from telling
you know racy material or things you
know that that are taboo definitely tell
those stories but it's important in this
level of heightened awareness to to put
your things through a sensitivity read
and I changed things about that script I
I took things out you know one thing
that I I kicked myself for are one of
our leads John in the script his his
character salt is Robert but Robert is a
double arm amputee and I wrote Robert
how I thought a double arm amputee would
be a very limited action very limited
movement and then we cast John Lawson
and my god that guy he is a private
pilot he can scuba dive he's an amazing
photographer as a writer when I
initially did I I limited him and it
took me meeting John and interacting and
really ingratiating myself at that
community to open myself up and that's
how you tell an authentic story what is
the sensitivity read so a sensitivity
read is to put your material in front of
you know a person that you are writing
about so let's just say that you're
writing about a disabled person or maybe
you're writing about somebody who has
HIV or maybe you're writing about an
immigrant maybe you're writing about
somebody with topical issues you know
and anything that can be considered
emotionally or politically charged so
dealing with issues of race color
economic class anything that can be
positive
possibly disparaging to a particular
group of people it's important that you
share those materials you you you put it
in front of you know readers and you do
a table read you know do we have actors
read the parts back to you and you know
there was in my play border
one of the feedback one of the pieces of
feedback that I'm working into I have
sort of a Greek chorus of Dia de los
Muertos characters and of course that's
you know that's something that's very
traditionally you know Mexican they're
in in my story they function as a Greek
chorus and they're kind of ominous
figures but I had a Latino cast and you
know two out of three of them were like
you really need to be a little bit more
positive with these guys because you
know the Dia de los Muertos is a way to
honor family and tradition and these
guys kind of come across as as baddies
and I'm like okay I didn't know that so
I was a writer you need to be open to
hearing those kinds of suggestions
because you know every everybody knows
the stories you know cowboys and Indians
you know what would a classically
machismo you know imperialistic way of
thinking and nothing would make that
movie these days it's it's it wouldn't
happen you know you go back and you look
at a lot of movies from your childhood
or than 90 xoring a lot of these raunchy
comedies they're creepy you know if you
you look at a lot of movies now like
especially in the 80s like that's rape
culture and that perpetuates things you
know people consume the media that you
write it's an it's important to have
people look at your materials to make
sure it kind of passes a smell test now
that's that's a that's a sensitivity
read interesting and what about the
criticism that somebody who hasn't been
through something shouldn't be allowed
to tell it I feel like in this climate
because somebody's voice may be censored
or they may be afraid to tell that story
that somebody else who may feel like I
don't know Society might view them as
they have more freedoms to tell a story
should be able to then get that story
out there I have to two things to say
about that the director of my play the
stage reading that we did she's Latin
acts amazing young auteur we had a
conversation you know we were getting
ready for pre-production
she asked me she said you are UV was
Hispanic descent I said no I'm not she
was what your Spanish that's pretty good
and I was like well I worked with the
translator so to get that going and she
asked me she goes why are you the one to
tell the story she's like you know you
were a white woman why are you the one
to to tell this story and my answer was
that no one else is telling it no one
else is telling this story and you know
regardless of my background or my skin
color or anything I live in this world
and these are issues that I care about
so if I care about them enough to try to
talk about them and to try to push them
out into the world you know my my story
may not be the end-all be-all you know
you know end of the subject matter it's
that's not going to be the case but this
is something that I care deeply about
and I you know I live in this world
I'm impacted by these issues too so
that's that's one way that I address
those particular questions I had a
general a couple weeks ago with another
production company a very well known
film company and you know as a writer
you're always constantly going through
I'm at least I am personally you know
self-doubt and kind of self-loathing and
thinking that you suck but she was
talking about a lot of the pieces that I
write and she noticed a common thread
the development exactly I was sitting
with she was like you tend to really
give characters that don't have a voice
a voice and I started to look back at
the pieces that I would write or that I
thought I'd been working on and you know
when you look at borderline that deals
with the immigration issues and to rumor
which deals with disability and I have
another one where the lead is a little
deaf girl and then you deal with
domestic violence issues and in
Baltimore and I didn't really realize
that and I mean even though you know I
didn't necessarily have the best
upbringing and I certainly struggled I
am
she said it very eloquently she goes
you're using your privilege to your
voice to those who don't have voice so
that's something I actually walked out
of the office a little teary but that
really rang true to me